you
hello in a very warm welcome to talking
Germany the show where we do just that
my guest today is a university professor
a best-selling author and a keen
controversialist for some he is a man
who dares to speak the truth for others
a troublemaker and a know-it-all here he
is in-person voter Kramer and I hope
you're okay with the introduction prob
so [ __ ] yeah now besides being a
full-time professor for business and
social statistics Valtor Kramer has also
published over 30 books and counting
they lambaste popular ignorance they
warn against the misuse of statistics
they highlight the angst of the Germans
they excoriate what he sees as the MAL
practices of the press and they defend
the German language against abuse it's
quite an agenda isn't of it perfect yeah
I got it all right how many books have
you written well so far it's about 40
years 40 no okay so I'm a little bit
behind with my count of 30 you're a
person with incredible energy written
all these books you're a professor
you've been involved in lots and lots of
public debates here in Germany in recent
years and in those debates we're going
to talk about the German language quite
a lot today in that so I'm going to use
a German word now in those debates
you're often described as kem Farish
yeah which in english is sort of feisty
yeah um what makes you so feisty what
makes you a sort of an angry man I think
that's not a one of my best I'm shuffler
characteristics I should be much more
come in discussion so I tend to well um
go too fast due to to be impolite with
the int'l I implied that is not one
thing one should do so that's why how
those characterizations in the media
came about that's where it comes from
yeah yeah when you were when you were a
youngster yeah Oh a wee little boy yeah
were you a troublemaker back then no
because we were living
the village and they were not that much
there's not that much chance of what 20
kids in the whole village so we were all
just bling game said what kids do in the
adage okie dokie you've one of your most
popular books in one of your most
popular books full stop is a book called
the dictionary of popular
misunderstandings and it's interesting
because i read that when you were a
small kid yeah and you didn't have other
too many other kids to sort of get on
your nerves you were you collected
mistakes right the people made yeah not
acceptable people in the media and most
come on you were collecting mistakes
being made by the media as a
seven-year-old boy I could read I could
read either we had a paper not our we
didn't have fun because we were quite
poorer than but there was one in the
village so I could have my clippings
yeah so I and when I went to high school
I made it a hobby listen to collect
curio cure curiosities of all types
things which later turned out to have
been wrong are you interested me and
collecting well I started collecting
lament once they how old were you when
you started collecting them this is a
fascinating business I think when I
could start reading the resort 77 years
old eight years old and you had the
newspaper spread out and you were
cutting out glucose things appear to me
is curious that cannot be true or how
come that this his soul yeah and then I
started asking my parents would you
usually didn't know either he asked my
teacher and he told me that them done
how things came about and then I started
a collection of curiosities okay give me
an example of one of the earliest
curiosities that you collected I have
still own folder back home oh really
what I haven't looked at it for about 20
years so you know have an example yeah
most of them were from sports and from
at that time science fiction was very
absolutely it was big day so I was
collecting a forecast of things to come
true which then happened no not rude to
turn out as they were forecasted okay
let's move forward to more recent times
this book the dictionary of popular
misunderstandings yeah give me give me
an example there of the popular
misunderstandings
trouble you in trouble Germany darkest
with a debate in the German Bundestag to
the fact that people smokers should be
made paying for their bad habits because
they are a they cost the health system
more than they pay in absolutely right
so somebody like me give you wrong
smokers without smokers the German
health care system would be broke within
a year in Los smokers thought that much
earlier the cost they avoid the system
by doing so say huge outweighs face who
yeah you're telling me that this is a
fact yeah or you're telling me this as
if it were a fat cards of my not me not
only as it barrels have collected
precise data for Switzerland and you can
view their important any decent library
and they found out that Switzerland
would have to pay more today for health
care if they had been nobody smoking
there for a debt for 100 years hmm so
the health care system would be more
expensive now than it really is if there
hadn't been any smoker for 100 years ok
so do I understand that you having said
told me all this see all these hard
facts from the Swiss researchers that
you are somebody you are somebody who
supports smokers support smoking and
would encourage smoking that's exactly
this is the first time that I have this
debate with somebody I thought the
inference then the common inference is
Oh Kramer is somebody who advocates
people to die a socially step as it was
called in a German Democratic Republic
for people who died with 65 that was a
socialist death was the normal way to
say goodbye to this we all know of
course everybody should become 100 years
old but we should not make the mistake
of thinking that investing more money in
avoiding diseases will make the health
care system as such in general cheaper
it may not make it even more expensive
ok point that was the first error okay
point taken the first error yeah okay
from first error is to first impressions
you have had your first impressions for
volta kramer here is more the campus of
Dortmund Technical University home to
the only statistics faculty in Germany
graduates from here should have no
worries finding a job patha crema has
been professor for economic and social
statistics at the University since 1988
his lectures are popular among students
because he likes to present statistics
as a practical discipline full of life
everyday items and phenomena are
recurring themes in his lectures perfect
for illustrating his insights I think
number crunching is boring think again
putting up he also shows how figures and
charts can be manipulated to distort
what numbers tell us he advises his
students to pack a pocket calculator and
a healthy degree of skepticism professor
Khaimah finds Germans predisposed to
panicking almost every day he'll come
across a scare mongering story in the
media that he says has little substance
professor Kramer has published over 40
books to date most of them concerning
popular science he's had a number of
bestsellers covering a range of topics
from popular misconceptions to his most
recent tome about the National traits of
Germans
after doing his military service as a
young man while tehama studied
mathematics and economics he's married
with two grown up children and one
grandson outside academia he's the
chairman of a German language
preservation association and a critic of
the eurozone bailout policy and he's
very outspoken in the stands of his
beloved Borussia Dortmund well on match
days at least
as well as attending their live matches
he also enjoys taking special stadium
tours
the professor leaves the stats aside to
enjoy this kind of hot seat and he's our
guest today on talking Germany matta
Kramer will be talking about Borussia
Dortmund later i'm very excited about
that first of all is it is a difficult
question for you night and i imagine
you're going to be able to give me the
answer what percentage of German men
have mustaches imp well since I have one
I tend to overestimate it I but I never
thought about that but neither yes is
about ten percent ten percent yeah it's
interested I have no idea what I'm sorry
it is intoxicated it occurred to me
spontaneously arose you're looking at
those pictures from your youth and
looking at you now obviously one in ten
maybe one in ten i don't know it's
interesting though that you'd like to
find out it yeah well you find out ok
yeah we could go on the internet now and
get a figure but that wouldn't be a very
reliable figure necessarily would it
yeah well the best thing in that case
and they just take a sample walk around
corphals and um and just check how many
men walk okay we have massage what you
do things it's interesting though when I
asked you you said that you said that
your perspective would influence your
the figure that you would estimate
because you are you yourself have a
mustache that tells us an awful lot
about statistics doesn't 10th right that
tells you that intuition a gut feeling
God field has a much greater impact on
the outcome than people hmm I think yeah
exactly there's a very popular a very
famous indeed English quotation which is
often attributed to Mark Twain yeah
although I'm not sure that he actually
coined it I don't know if you know where
i'm going yet yeah yeah kinds of lies no
no no no no well yeah there are lies
there are damned lies and there are
statistics yeah you are yes is your
profession you are a statistician yes
that's this quote which is a wonderful
quote from Mark Twain it doesn't cast a
very positive light on your on your
profession does it well statistics
numbers can be abused like
words text also we can be abused so
that's normal in fact in the anglo-saxon
we all statistics are beauty in a much
better and more favorable way for
instance Amos quote attributed Churchill
that don't trust as this statistic which
you don't have many plane to yourself
it's a good one it's not your hair never
been said by Churchill it has been
attributed to him by yours of gobbles in
World War truth oh lordy I did not know
that or put him in did this disrepute
among the germ said that iron so
Churchill was a major admirer of
statistics here among his advisors he
always had sir decisions and is the
quote office which I like best is you
have to look the facts in the eyes
before the facts look at you that's good
as well as much better interesting what
why were you drawn to statistics in the
first place it's a very dry science it
isn't it doesn't it is just these signs
of well making things a parent looking
behind the screens looking at facts not
at what you think are facts maybe that
has to do with my hobby of collecting
mistake we're going back to the
youngster here yeah you were what you
were born in nineteen forty eight so
it's just three years after the end of
the Second World War hard times here in
Germany can you you mentioned it i think
in passing earlier that's right you hard
times for your family well we I grew up
close to the best of all at the Belgium
Belgium water where there was the big
hard are then enough ovens even at the
end of the war again offensive expensive
so I used to play in the Hudson comedy
trenches Metro still left and one of our
favorite hobbies was to collect shells
which are small shells we have an
exploded right throwing him the fire and
watch them explode so really uh-huh that
but i did a sense all of the kids in my
neighborhood were as poor as we were
yeah you don't feel that so it was a
happy childhood in fact
in 1969 I think it's fair to say you
went off to begin your studies this was
a this is the end of the 60s 1968
student protests of that were you ever a
long-haired student protester for a
while for a while long hair unless it
were what were you angry about back then
I was angry boss ever else was angry so
I didn't think very hard about all this
that was just the feeling of the time
yeah all my colleagues all my friends
were angry so I had to be angry as well
which lasted about three month the wrong
here lasted longer and then they you've
had a very successful career you were a
professor by the time by 1988 are pretty
good pretty rapid run yeah that's a 4888
that's not a fast track yeah but from
the time you weren't actually off to
university anyway you've written a lot
of very successful but you better how
grateful are you for the fact that the
post-war Germany that you have grown up
in that you've lived your life in has
been so peaceful and so prosperous well
when I was a young read and think about
that at all mm-hmm later on I think it
was luck it was the Cold War for
instance that made the Americans the
British thinking differently about
Germany they needed it as a help against
the Russians if the Cold War hadn't
happened where things would have come
out quite differently yeah one reason
why I'm asking you might be wondering
why I'm asking you about gratitude
because it because I think there's a
huge sort of debate in German and I
think it's part of what your new book is
about a little bit about the Germans
about how the Germans see themselves and
one at the core of that very often when
people are talking about the Germans is
the extent to which Germans are grateful
for what they have are comfortable with
what they have or the extent to which
perhaps they moan too much it is often
said that people moan too much and you
are one of the people who tends to say
that that's right so um there is a
widespread attitude and not to be happy
with things as they are to complain
about the weather complain about your
workplace complain about a
whatever a rather than taking things as
they are and making the best out of it
which is more the anglo-saxon attitude
what's events there's a new phrase in
German which we which has been in sort
of in the language for the last year or
two now called the root burger yeah
again I'm going to use one or two German
terms today would you like to explain
for our audience what a vote burger is
well people who think they have the
right tool behave outrageously because
they have detected some evil which they
will now make disappear I don't like
those people at all do you often wonder
you do not wander yourself sometimes
whether you aren't a little bit of a
vote or get yourself set an angry
citizens them because what you it
sometimes seems to me that what you're
doing is shaking your fist about the
people who are shaking their fists well
in writing indeed that's all in my books
I've many sorry stories about people who
were originated who invented this dioxin
panic in January 2010 which was the last
public affair of that sort which hit our
country which comes every two or three
years there we have one of such panics
public panics occurring and then I
really get angry about the people who
fuel these things and without thinking
twice and without thinking of the
consequences okay we'll talk about
exactly that in just a second now we're
moving quickly now from panic to angst
one thing that people associate with
Germany and Germans is angst the german
word for fear that has of course also
been adopted in the english language no
Valda Kramer has used his skill as a
statistician to take a close look at
just how much angst there really is in
Germany and where it comes from
you have to tell me a little bit about
your methodology they have vowed to
crema de it looks like you're cutting
out little bits of newspaper newspaper
cuttings once again no no that time in
fact I did real research okay I had the
content of major newspapers yeah scanned
for 10 years 2000 until the end of 2010
and checking how many articles are
devoted to topics like dioxin or nuclear
power accidents and panic themes of all
source and this was quite time consuming
a lot of in require a lot of effort and
so this was real hard hard work not just
paper clipping and you discovered you
are telling me that the Germans have
more angst in the Italians or the Brits
or the Americans or so the one of the
results of that research was that
leading German newspapers like pseudo to
tighten or frankfurt on shaw publish
about four times as much angst stories
or panic articles then let's say Figaro
or like a publically tell you it's hard
for me to believe that because I work in
the media and because I know but for you
I mean you're mentioning newspapers I
know journalists who work there and and
I you know my english language speaking
colleagues are always saying oh the
Germans they're so slow to get a
headline they're so slow to make a story
they they they stick to the facts
they're so boring here and you're
telling me that all they do is kick up
sensations all the time well but if
there's anniversary of some excellent
like Fukushima that happened about three
years ago so there's no every year
Fukushima memory memorial story in
Rizzuto recital there's none in The
Times there's none in La Repubblica
there's none in la figa that's to say
it's very ritualized that kind of thing
I ended I take your point but I mean
there's a bigger point here that I mean
you know one or two of the things you're
talking about when you talk about BSE or
something like that that the the Germans
are very concerned about nature about
health about what they eat and to be
honest that has to be a good thing well
to be concerned about what you eat
is of course good for your health but it
starts to become a nuisance when you get
worried by minimum amounts of pesticides
in your food which will never ever in
danger anybody like in during that
famous types in panic in January 2010
where they discovered three billions of
a crab of dioxygen eggs you had you
would have had to eat about a ton per
day until this had become a danger to
your health and people nevertheless
started panicking and that's what makes
me angry mmm you we've talked about the
Germans in general and you've written
about the Germans in general and when we
talk about the Germans and angst you
know what comes to mind for me most
spontaneously Germans have angst are
frightened of or have fear of the war
for example that's there has to be a
good thing well that's one lesson or
they are fluent but I think this is even
in great much deeper there's one theory
by the famous Swiss psychologist Carl
Gustav Jung who has termed the what the
Germans called collective is on tables
and collective collective subconscious
of consciousness and according to you
this collective subconsciousness of
people living what's not Germany is
still formed by one of the worst
experiences ever happening any part of
the world is the thirty years war which
the British I think don't know much
about because it didn't if there's a
long long long time ago long time ago
and you're and affect them but for the
people living here about one third of
people living here diet by force in a
very short time so according to young
this has shaped these collective
subconscious something in it I mean that
you know the English are always talking
about how the country hasn't been
invaded since 1066 and they act as
though the collective memory goes right
back to them who knows maybe it does i'm
not that i'm not an expert on that let's
talk about the present though a little
bit you to you are often acting as
though the Germans are very angst-ridden
are very uptight a very tense but most
of the foreign visitors and a lot of
people inside Germany like you say that
but a lot of the foreign visitors
I me to come to Germany tell me what a
revelation this is all these Germans
they're so cool they're so relaxed
they're so easy going to use a very
English language phrase yeah why won't
you guys buy into that I mean since the
2006 world cup everybody's been coming
to Germany and saying wow what a country
oh I think that is not one of the major
were all bonded plus points being easy
going to the walking though crystal an
on-base go to the being tortured by
angst surely um no I mean that's just
not true just look walk around Koufos
and dumb watch the people are washed I
should explain you've mentioned it now
they cover the coffers and damaged one
of the most prestigious and best-known
boulevards here in Berlin yeah well if
you walked on there I think people are
still looking at you in a more concerned
where then they would look at you at the
Via Veneto in Rome for instance or in
Milan or in Paris so they still ever
worrisome attitude towards what is
happening mm-hmm here's a quote you said
too many journalists to see themselves
as preachers and do-gooders who believe
they can change the world for the better
that's right that's one of the
second-tier I have how come that you're
talking about me here you know that
German angst has made it as one of the
few words german words in foreign
languages next to cal gustav jung and
his theory of the collective
subconsciousness there is another theory
by you on Galton a very famous Norwegian
scientists who has termed the phrase of
the typical anglo-saxon French and
German intellectual style of thinking
yeah and the corner to Galton
anglo-saxons tend to be problem solvers
they solve one problem and then go to
the next one not worrying about whether
the theory they used for the problem a
is also good for problem be restroom
thinkers like Hagel marks luta want or
Einstein want to build a real formula
they want to build one big pyramid which
they then defend with all their forces
until the very end because if there's
is this is attack the whole life will be
ruined and which makes them so stiff and
so devoid of humor German scientists and
journalists are also intellectuals at
least they like to see themselves as
such and if they have detected one big
enemy like nuclear power they will fight
it until the very end and won't stop
until it has been destroyed okay you've
had your say we're going to have to
agree to differ I for one am a
journalist who is proud to be an
intellectual I don't think it means
anything about me I think it means that
you're passionate about ideas yeah maybe
we can agree on that he's not on yeah
it's all quite amusing really but there
is a very serious side to this story and
I know that's the side that you see you
know for me the English language is a
lovely language yeah it's sort of being
adopted in many ways in Germany what's
the problem of first of all it's in many
senses an advantage that there is one
language which you can use all across
Europe you can buy cappuccino in Rome
well which I probably couldn't do in the
Italian and if the Italian waiter didn't
speak English I would have a problem so
let's no doubt that there are lots of
advantages to it but the disadvantages
start to crop up when you stop using
your own language even when you could
have used it and that's what is
happening in Germany on a big scale and
that really drives me crazy mmm you set
up in in 1997 this society what was it
called the Association for the
protection of the German language at
that time it's now called the German
language association just explain to me
a little bit more about how you protect
a language how can you actually do it
because this is happening on a language
is spontaneously I just happens thought
I think the German language also be
spoken in 100 years but if we don't take
care it will be only spoken in the
kindergarten but not in universities not
in the offices of tax firms and in the
business blue-chip companies include to
becomes is already happening i was
reading about DNA and motor than the
alliance insurance in munich recent
image that going polish company language
that's art which i think is a big
mistake because then
your language becomes kind of a dialect
you cannot do science with that language
anymore and that's one thing which I
think should we should do something
against that yeah what what exactly is
there something I could do something be
for instance we should continue teaching
courses at the universes in German lots
of my colleagues are proud that they can
in semi proficient English teachers
their courses to German students which i
think is ridiculous yeah also I almost
many other papers are published in
English I still do publish some in
German just to keep German as a language
of the sciences alive and there is a
real real danger that our language won't
be a medium for communication in science
in business anymore within a couple of
years if we don't mmm something although
it is very interesting what you're
saying is I mean maybe it's true what
you're saying maybe your fears are
well-founded but certainly the Germany
that I live in that I move around it I
mean I'm the kind of person who reads an
awful lot and I I in recent years have
been reading a lot of German language
novels novels in German by German
writers who are German turkish-german
persian german polish German Ukraine
writers it's a fantastic things and and
that's a kind of a vibrancy in the
language and also at the same time you
know when i'm sitting on the underground
here in Berlin I'm often sitting with
people who it's very very clear they
have two languages and that's a great
thing because it doesn't mean that
they're speaking the German less it
means that they're understanding their
awareness of language is greater their
their passion for language is greater
and that's making German a more again a
more vibrant language oh well you have
to make a difference if you'll grow up
speaking two languages like my
grandchild is doing at the moment she's
talking German and it Japanese and by
the way German and Japanese Legation
finish so it's wonderful so if you run a
parent speaking one language the other
Pandava that's the optimal yeah the best
thing that could happen to a child but
going to kindergarten and then being
interred
to some sloppy English phrases by the
kindergarten mrs. is what is happening
Germany at the moment on a big scale is
a nonsense nuisance it's the sloppiness
that makes you angry is the rescission
in the use of language these poor kids
won't learn neither German or English so
they will be handicapped all through
their lives learning a language can most
of the cases only be done either if your
parents speak it or if you live there
for a while in that country you have
been living here for a while you speak
perfect German but learning German in
England I think who how many dozen
people have managed that in a century
not many more used to do it in the olden
days that's how people used to learn
languages yeah ok what we don't have to
agree to differ here we can just agree
to be see it sort of from slightly
different angles ok yeah one thing I
think we will agree about is is the you
know for both of us soccer is a great
passion both for Valtor Kramer and for
me and we're going to have a look now at
one of his favorite football clubs not
his favorite football club indeed
Borussia Dortmund it is the best
supported team in Europe I have learnt
let's have a look at this report and
then we'll talk about about the club and
about his enthusiasm
be foul be a bro see a doorman d of
course am a wonderful dortmund toaster
there I wouldn't mind one of those
throughout the creamer you are a very
dedicated Dortmund fan yeah well the
shareholder and a shell the first of all
as a fan where did it were where did
that come from where did that start well
you have to be a fan of some club so I
grabbed in fact in mind so I soon also a
supporter of mental filth because I
started there and lived there for 20
years but already before I went to da
moon I followed them on TV and they were
my favorite Club for decades I still
remember when they won against Benfica
lissabon in 1963 ago I'm time ago I'm as
it were yesterday yeah and what were you
there or were you listening to this on
the radio voted on TV he was on TV oh
yeah and when they won against i think
it was west ham united in 1965 uh-huh I
think 20 by their goals by health and a
militia I think so remember that
sometimes for decades and I very happy
that they are so good at the moment okay
and you just mentioned the fact I mean
you are you are a professor for Business
Studies and the economics effectively
and you're a shareholder in the in the
Dortmund club they're the only stock
marketed stock market listed club in
Germany so does that mean they're fat
cats that they're so does the
capitalists of German soccer no I think
the idea was just to make every dog
murderer even more a fan so they shares
initially cost 11 years now they are 360
at one time they were eighty cents so if
you then entered the market you made a
big revenue out of that um you're
talking about yourself here i started at
all prices i started when they were 11
okay 862 180 census kept buying i kept
buying yeah so it's not even a fair at
the moment tell me everybody or a lot of
people the vast majority of our viewers
I think we'll know about the rivalry the
current rivalry between borussia
dortmund and Bayern Munich yeah and i
just mentioned the word class is it a
class war a class difference between the
two sides Oscar what's going on there in
a sense of course document is war pot
belly rub valet
for class of the industrial heartland in
Germany yeah Ireland Bayern Munich oras
has been chica mica Correa society and
Bayern Munich as a club is for fancy
pants Club fancy pants so in a sense
there is some kind of class war going on
here okay do you know the Borussia
Dortmund songs I mean when you go along
to the match head skin and know them but
I i think the Liverpool songs are better
i love the Liverpool songs now they are
very great fans when they're when
they're singing the last question do you
have a season ticket no because I'm
always watching midweek games because my
family lives elsewhere so I'm not there
and on the weekend you're a commuter yes
right how much does a season ticket cost
him all of the cheap season tickets [ __ ]
that never even tried to buy one but I
think it is about 500 for people from
abroad sounds like very very little
money indeed people are always talking
about how inexpensive a bundesliga isn't
for top quality football that is really
very good indeed okay vota claim all
gonna move on to our quiz at the end of
the show we don't have time when
Dortmund played by in next time is it
going to be angst or hope well it's I'm
sure they will win hope that's your lot
with the feisty voter Kramer there's
more talking Germany on our website if
you've enjoyed his company as much as I
have do come back next bye bye Andres
you